[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام الم تخرج
القوات الدوليه خلسه من افغانستان بعد 13
عاما تاركه وراءها حركه طالبان وتنظيم
القاعده اكثر
[موسيقى]
قوه الم يفشل الناتو بقوته الجويه والبريه
في القضاء على الجهاديين
هناك الم تضطر امريكا بعد كل ذلك الى
التفاوض مع طالبان واخواتها الا يعتبر
الانسحاب الدولي من افغانستان دون اي ضجه
اع يه هزيمه لصالح الجماعات الجهاديه
الجديده التي تجتاح سوريا والعراق كتنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه
وشركائها الا يتحقق شعار التنظيم باقي
وتتمدد يوما بعد يوم الا تبلغ المساحه
التي يسيطر عليها التنظيم ضعف مساحه سوريا
الا تصل نسبه التاييد للجماعات الجهاديه
في المنطقه الى اكثر من 90% في بعض
البلدان وكذلك ايضا في الدول الغربيه اليس
ظهور الجهاديين بقوه على المسرح نتيجه
طبيعيه للسياسات الدوليه والمحليه البائسه
لماذا تحركت امريكا وشركائها لمواجهه
الدوله الاسلاميه فورا بينما تركت بشار
الاسد يستخدم كل الاسلحه الم حرم دوليا ضد
الشعب السوري اليس من شان ذلك ان يدفع
بالمزيد من المؤيدين الى صفوف
الجهاديين هل الارهاب السني حرام والارهاب
الشيعي
حلال لكن في المقابل ماذا انتجت الجماعات
الجهاديه في البلدان التي سيطرت عليها غير
التخلف والجهل والتطرف اليس من السخف ان
يتخذ البعض من افغانستان قدوه لهم
ماذا يستفيد الافغان من خروج القوات
الدوليه غير مزيد من القهر اليس هناك
اجماع دولي واقليمي وعربي على مواجهه
الدوله الاسلاميه واخواتها وهزيمتها عاجلا
او اجلا ماذا استفادت الثوره في سوريا او
العراق من ظهور الجهاديين الم يحرفوا
الثورات عن مسارها وجعلوا العالم يتعامل
معها على انها حركات ارهابيه اليس بشار
الاسد فرحا بالتحالف الدولي الذي الذي
يقاتل داعش الان على الارض السوريه
والعراقيه هل ثارت شعوب المنطقه اصلا
لاستبدال مرض الفالج المتمثله بالدكتاتور
العسكريه بمرض السرطان المتمثله بالجماعات
المتطرفه اسئله اطرحها على الهواء مباشره
على السيد حسين محمد حسين الخبير والباحث
في شؤون الخلافه الاسلاميه وعلى السياسي
الكرديه السيد شرزاد اليزيدي نبدا نقاش
بعد
الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام نحن
معكم على الهواء مباشره في برنامج الاتجاه
المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على موضوع هذه
الحلقه هل تعتقد ان التحالف الدوليه سيقضي
على الدوله الاسلاميه واخواتها صوت على
صفحه الاتجاه المعاكس اكثر من
90.4 لا لن يقضي على الدوله الاسلاميه 9.6
سيقضي عليها سيد حسين لو بدات معك بهذه
النتيجه وبسؤال
اخر ماذا يمكن ان نقرا انت تعلم ان القوات
الدوليه موجوده في افغانستان منذ اكثر من
13 عاما قبل ايام بدات هذه القوات تخرج من
افغانستان خلسه دون ضجه اعلاميه لم نسمع
احد يتحدث عن خروج هذه القوات من
افغانستان اه تاركه وراءها طالبان حركه
طالبان على مشارف كابول ماشي كيف يمكن ان
يؤثر ذلك الان على صعود جماعات اخرى غير
طالبان في المنطقه كتنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه واخواتها بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه
والسلام على نبينا محمد واله وصحبه اجمعين
والحمد لله الذي شرفني ببيعه امير
المؤمنين ابي بكر
البغدادي شاء من شاء وابى من ابى هذا اولا
اما خروج الصليبيين من افغانستان انا لن
احيلك الى مصادر اعلاميه ولا الى تقارير
اعلاميه ودراسات استقصائيه انما اضعها بين
يديك هكذا لكن احيلك الى من تعرفها
بالرصانة دون ال 100 و2 الف اان ونصف
مليون امريكي اصيب منهم واحد ونصف مختلف
الاصابات تقدم منهم بشكوى العاهد دائمه
750 ال و50 الف 750 الف عاه دائمه طالبوا
بالاحاله العاهد دائمه هذه الحرب خلال 10
سنوات كانت من في اخر عشر سنوات كانت لقد
كانت الحرب تقول هي لقد كانت الحرب مكلف
خلال اخر عشر سنوات م مكلفه جدا ولو ان
الاعتراف الرسمي كان فقط ب 50 الف قتيل
بنيران مع والحقيقه انهم اكثر من 600000
وهذه من جامعه هارفرد وليست من
الاعلام منهم 253 الف اذيه دماغيه مع
قابليه الاصابه الاصابات دعني اكمل ارجوك
مع مع قابليه الاصابات الدائمه للتفاقم
الى صرع واختلاجات دائمه وعاهات دائمه
وخرف ونقص في الاستعاب الذهني والفهم
ازدياد تكاليف علاج العسكريين من 18 مليار
دولار عام 2001 الى 56 مليار دولار عام
2013 وهناك ديون مستحقه على الخزينه
العامه تغطيه تكاليف الحربين بقيمه 2
ترليون مليون د افغانستان والعراق كل تلك
التكاليف تعني ا اخر الكلمه كل تلك
التكاليف فديون انتجت اختلالات في
الاقتصاد الامريكي وغلاء في المعيشه وشكلت
عبع على الاقتصاد الامريكي بقيمه 6
تريليون
دولار مراقبون اخرون على هذه على ضوء هذه
الدراسه قدروا ان الوضع اذا استمر على هذه
الحال فسوف ترتفع التكلفه الى 18 تريليون
دولار ا هذا هو الخازوق في عام 2017 اذا
وصل الحال هذا هو الخازوق الذي دع مع
الصليبيين الى الهرب صمت وبمنتهى الذله اغ
ومنتهى الذله ما الذي اهداف كثيره زعموا
تحقيقها ديمقراطيه وبطيخ مبسمر
وماذا كرزاي الولد الصايع المايع لا يملك
ان يحل كما يقول عوام دكه سروالي ماشي هذا
شيء طيب تفضل السؤال المطروح الان كيف
يمكن ان نقرا يعني نقرا ذلك على ضوء
اجتياح جماعات اخرى للمنطقه العربيه سوريا
الع كذا اخ باختصار الجهاد فريضه محكمه
تقوم بها دوله
الخلافه ظهرت بذور الجهاد في افغانستان ثم
تكالبت عليهم الامم وضيق عليهم لكن الفكره
نشات الفكره نشات وتلقاها الش الشباب
المسلم تزامنت مع الياس من السلاحف الذين
تنازلوا عن كل شيء تنازلوا عن سناء
تنازلوا عن اليمن والان تطبخ طبخه نجران
طيب اسمع والربع الخالي والربع الخالي
الذي يمنع حتى على جوجل ايرث ان يصور بعض
المناطق فيه بيعه للشركات اليهوديه
والامريكيه لتستخرج منه اليورانيوم والذهب
وبصمت طيب ماشي السؤال يعني لم تجبني
باختصار شديد اريد كيف يمكن ان نفهم
الانسحاب وتاثيره على على جماعات اخ هذا
اول بوادر النصر وهذا اول بوادر الهزيمه
للقوات الصليبيه والقوات الكفر عامه طيب
جميل جدا كيف ترد على هذا الكلام يعني
يقول الان انه بصراحه كل الهيصه الدوليه
الان عن مقاتله تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
واخواتها
اه يعني اصبح في في خبر كان على ضوء
الهزيمه الامريكيه النكراء او الهزيمه
الغربيه النكراء في افغانستان خرجوا من
افغانستان بصمت كما قال لك بينما الان نجد
الدوله الاسلاميه او تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه يسيطر على ضعف مساحه سوريا هل
تعلم ان مساحه الدوله الاسلاميه الان اكبر
من مساحه سوريا بمره كيف ترد على هذا
الكلام يعني وهل انت مقتنع انها الدوله
ويليق ان نسميها الوله اسلاميه انا اصلا
اصلا اربا بالدين الاسلامي الحنيف ان يتم
قرنه بهذه العصابه هي عباره عن مجاميع
ارهابيه هي الشكل الجديد شتم انت الان
تشتم المسلمين لا هذه دوله الخلافه ش داعش
لا تمثل المسلمين لا تمثلني وتمثل
المسلمين ي مقاطعه لا اقا لسانه على دول
الاسلام اوقف البرنامج اذا سي
حسين
ت مجرمي كردستان لا يمثلون الاكراد ابدم
الاكراد هذه دراسه
استقصائيه سيد حسين سيد حسين اطي اعطي
انطباع كويس عن لا لا دقيقه خليني اوقفوا
بس دقيقه سيد حسين انا اتفقت انه لا تقاطع
باي طريقه من الطرق خليه يخلص مثل ما انت
تكلمت ما حدا ش
هذا
التوصيف هذه
تقتل وسرق وتسبي يقتلون العرب قبل الغير ي
سنه البويه يا اخي دقيقه اكمل تفضل نعم
هذه جاوبني على سؤالي بدون ما ندخل جاوبني
على سؤالي كيف يقول لك الرجل هذه الجماعات
الان بعد بعد الهزيمه الامريكيه في
افغانستان باقيه وتتمدد كيف ترد باقيه
وتتمدد هذه عصابات جماعات ظ
تكفيريه عصر حجريه بصراحه هذه لا مستقبل
لها هذه حاله شاذه مؤقته خاصه هذا التنظيم
المسمى هذا التنظيم المسخ داعش هذا نتاج
فشل تلك الموجه التي استبشرت بها شعوب
المنطقه خاصه في سوريا خيرا بتغيير النظام
واقامه سوريا جديده ديمقراطيه تعدديه لا
مركزيه يتعايش فيها السوريون مختلف
المكونات السوريه السوريين لم ينتفضوا قبل
ثلاث اعوام ونصف كي يكون البديل خلافه
داعش واخواتها من جبهه هؤلاء الان يقتلون
السوريون يقاتلون الجيش الحر في
ادلب عبر اليومين الماضيين يقاتلون الكرد
الكرد السوريين في كوباني وفي مناطقنا في
كانتونات هنا في روج افا هذه لا مستقبل
لها هي خارج التاريخ هذه جماعات مخلب قط
تستخدم من قبل اجندات وقوى مختلفه مثلا
تركيا استخدمتها ضدنا امض سه حق هذه
جماعات تستخدم في تسعير الحروب الطائفيه
والمذهبيه لواد الثورات التي قامت ولواد
التحول الديمقراطي هذه جماعات هي وجه اخر
بل واقبح واسوا من النظم الاستبداديه التي
طيلت يعني تتذكرون جميعنا نتذكر الموجه
القوميه في الستينات والسبعينات
والثمانينات والنظم البعثيه في العراق
وسوريا وبقيه يعني ماذا كان مال حصادها ما
نرى الان بعد يعني في القرن الحادي والعشر
هذه الدول دولنا ومجتمعاتنا بفعل هذا
الاستبداد المديد تعلن فيها الان خلافه
ويعلن امير المؤمنين ويتم سبي سبي بنات
الناس المدنيين و وتقطع رقبنا هذا ارهاب
موصو هذه وحشيه وهذا النكوص الى الى ما
قبل الى القرون الوط قبل القرون الو قبل
الى العصور الحجريه جميل بس خليني خليني
بس مشان طيب ماشي ماشي اذا كانت هذه
الجماعات كما تقول كل ما قلته ويعني هذا
من حقك ان تقل ما تشاء والضيف الا يقول
مايقول هذه ماذا تقرا نعم بس لكن هناك
لدينا معطيات الان
لدينا هزيمه امريكيه تحدث لك عن مضاعفاتها
الاقتصاديه بشهاده جامعه هارفد اه هارفارد
نعم هزيمه امريكيه في افغانستان او هزيمه
غربيه لم تستطع هذه القوات برا وجوا دكتور
دكتور دكتور دقيقه هذا السؤال لنا
لمجتمعاتنا لشعوبنا للعالم العربي
والاسلامي يعني السؤال هو نحن يجب ان
ننتصر على هذا الفكر الظلامي وهذه الظاهره
هذا السرطان هذه حركه فاشيه بصراحه فاشيه
دينيه هذه هذه تقتل تكفر تسبي نساء
الناس هذه القتل تمارس القتل للقتل ليس
لديها لا مبدا لا اخلاق عديمه الصله
بالانسانيه داعش الان وصمه عار في جبين
الانسانيه ككل هذه عصابات هذه تريد العوده
بالبشريه الى الاف السنين للخلف يعني جميل
جدا جميل جدا كويس كيف ترد بس بهدوء مثل
ما هو يتحدث
بمنطق دقيقه
دقيقه لا لا بس بدون تشريح وبدون شخص
الرجل ما شخص الرجل ما شخص بس انا بدي
اسالك بدي اسالك بدي اسالك يعني هل تستطيع
ان تنكر الان ان هناك تحالفا دوليا عربيا
اقليميا للوقوف في وجه هذه الجماعات لن
يكتب لها النجاح بهدوء تفضل اخي هذه
المصطلحات لا تلزمنا نحن امه الاسلام امه
مليار ونصف مسلم طيب سرق حقنا في دوله
اسلاميه ذات تحفظ علينا كرامتنا حتى اذا
بعث الله لنا من ينقذنا من هذا الذل الذي
مضى عليه 100 عام واكثر منذ ان تامر العرب
وتامر الكرد وتامر غيرهم من القوم
وكل الاحزاب التي تراها اليوم ذات نفس
قومي قذر لا لا لا لا يعني لا يعنيه الا
الحزبيه التي هو فيها فقط وليس لا اكراد
ولا عرب ولا غيره ط نحن من حقنا ان هذه
الامه من حقها ان تكون لها دوله وخلافه
وهذه الخلافه الان بفضل الله تعالى تعتقد
انه هناك بذور خلافه الان الان ليس بذور
خلافه هناك خلافه قائمه لا يعذر مسلم بي
بالتاخر عن بيعتها ساعه واحده اها عرفت
اشرح لي كيف اشرح لك هذا فر يقول عليه
الصلاه والسلام بس اشرح لي الان اشرح لي
الان لا الان ابن الحديث الشريف لابد ان
تبني على على اصل ديني
لا من مات وليس في عنقه بيعه مات ميته
جاهليه وبالتالي لا يحل لمسلم ان يتخلف عن
البيع هذا اولا ثانيا الفساد والعهر وحتى
التعتيم الاعلامي انا اعطيك مثال صغير هذه
التصويت الذي هو 90% رغم ان هناك من دول
تصدر بس بدون بدون بدون بدون ما تدخلي
بالشو اسمه خليني بالعموميات تفضل
بالعموميات مع كل التعتيم والتشو
احام سبي الكفره ح من احكام الشرع اسر
الكافر وقت حكم من احكام الشرع رضي من رضي
وسخط من سقط دوله الاسلام لا تنتظر ان
يعترف بها من ينتظر هذا وامثاله ان يعترف
به من الكفار والصليبين واليهود لا تنتظر
ان يعت ان يعترف بها من باعوا كركوك
لليهود الان عقارات كركوك
تباع دقيقه طيب اكمل
اكمل اكثر من ذلك نحن هذه دوله هل تعرف
دوله في التاريخ كله تستطيع ان تقاتل كل
دول العالم وفي محيط حدودها البالغ ما
يزيد على 6000 اسمع ما يزيد على 6000 ك م
جبهات مشتعله تديرها اما ما
يسمونه معلومات اما ما يسمونه مقبرت مقبره
داعش
واض اما ما يسمى وهو عين الاسلام اذا كان
مسلما يقول عين الاان مم انتهينا لا
تقطع تعرب ولا تكفر باسم لا لا باسم
الاسلام شئت بيت وهذا دين الله انتبه وانت
وكل
تال
عينه خل كمل تفضل هذه هل هل يعني خلينا
نخصص الموضوع من المهاره العسكريه في دوله
الخلافه انها جعلت هذه البؤره مصيده لكل
هؤلاء المرتزقه
مص لا شو الافاق الذين تقاتل معهم بنات
يحملون يحملنا زجاجات الخمر كلما اسرت
واحده لا انا اتيك كلما اسرت واحده من
البيكي او الطرمه يؤسر يوجد معها في
حقيبتها لا موجود
رر لاذنا قبل رجالنا يدعسون على
ي الرجال لا تقاتل بالنساء الرجال لا ت
بالساءق معلا بالجال الين عند
عنده كمل خلكم
اطيني دقيق خلينا بدون مقاطعه قلنا بدون
مقاطعه بدون مقاطعه بدون مقاطعه طيب كيف
ترد على الذين يقولون ان طيب انت الان
تطبل وتزمر لهذه الجماعات كما يا اخي
دقيقه دقيقه دوله شو دوله شو
دقيقه خليني اكمل خليني اكمل انا بدي اسال
بس خليني اسال هل تستطيع ان تنكر بان هذه
الجماعات هي عباره عن مسمار جحا خليني كمل
وجاوبني مسمار جحه يخ يستخدمونها
استخدموها في اكثر من مكان وكانت النتيجه
تدمير البلدان العراق دمر بسببها
افغانستان دمرت بسببها الان سوريا تدمر
بسببها هذه مخلب قط يضعه كبار العالم
ويلعبون
فيهاش دكتور فيصل مسمار جحه ليست مسمار
جحه كيف دمر العراق هل دمر العراق لانه
كانت فيه قاعده دمر العراق من اجل البترول
من اجل جورج بوش جاء من اجل البترول ولم
تكن هناك قاعده في العراق طيب ولم يكن
هناك اي شيء اسمه اسلامي او حكم
اسلامي تسكت الله يرض عليك بس بالله خلينا
بدون مقاطعه تفضل في افغانستان ما الذي
اخذ امريكا الى افغانستان لتدمر وكي على
الخلق هي لا انما هي حروب استعماريه
لحسابات معينه ليس اكثر وانت تعلم الشان
الاستعماري في للدول الغربيه هنا وهناك
بحيث انه تج توجد كل المبررات لتدمر
المسلمين الحقيقه هي حربون على الاسلام
كذبنا صدقنا يا اخي اسكت رجا تفضل تفضل
تفضل
اكمل هي لتدمير الاسلام ومنع قيام الخلافه
الذي لم يكون م لم يكن محسوبا حسابه بعد
كل هذه المرمطه بالام العربيه دقيقه هل
تعطيني معلومات انت تدعو الى دوله خلافه
باختصار وتقول دوله خلافه احكي لي بدون ما
تعطيني شعارات وايات وحدي اعطيني وقع على
الارض وقع على الارض الان الناس تعيش في
ظل دوله الخلافه في حاله اقتصاديه ممتازه
وين في في في كل مطق في مدينه الخير في
الرقه في الموصل يجدون عزا وحاله من من
العز ليس لها مثيل لكن اعلامنا حتى اعلام
الجزيره حتى مراسلي الجزيره من حزب العم
حزب التحد الكردستاني عرفت لذلك هذا
التعتيم هذا التعتيم هذا التعتيم هذا
التقم هو الذي يعطي للناس صوره مفاسده لكن
الناس لكن المسلمين لا ينخدعون بذلك بل
هناك بيعات ت خليك وقف عند بيعات خليك وقف
بس بدون مقاطعه انا بدي اسال بس خليني
اسالك طيب كيف ترد بصراحه انا بدي
اسالك مثل ما سالته نعم هل تعلم الان ان
في بعض الدول وهناك احصائيات موثقه قامت
بها مراكز بحوث ووكالات استخبارات نعم لن
اذكر الاسماء لكن في اكثر من مكان في
العالم العربي نسبه التاييد للدوله
الاسلاميه في بعض البلدان تزيد على ال 90%
واخر استطلاعات اجريت على الجاليات
المسلمه وغير المسلمه في اوروبا وصل
التاييد للدوله الاسلاميه على عكس كل ما
تسمع بالاعلام الى اكثر من ث % اذا انت
صفها كما تشاء قل عنها ما تشاء لكن على
الارض واقع واقع هذا ليس توصيل ماشي كيف
تفسر لي طيب ماشي كيف تفسر هذا الدعم
الهائل لهذه الحركات الان جاوبني يا رجل
هؤلاء خلال اليومين خلال اليومين خلال
اليومين الماضيين يعني هذه احصاءات يعني
كل مؤسسه حسب العينه التي تختار اصات بدون
ما اعطيك الباس بس موثوقه 100% تفضل يعني
خلينا ه الاات بس دقيقه الاحصاءات الغربيه
الاحصاءات التي نشرتها الصحف الغربيه
والبريطانيه تمان هذه مشكوك فيها طيب طيب
خلينا هلا هلا عشيره البونمر عشيره من
العرب السنه ومن كبريات العشائر في
الانبار في
العراق في اليومين الماضيين تابع الجزيره
تابع اخبار العالم كلها قتل اكثر من 500
يعني مدني من ابناء هذه العشائر على يد
هذه العصابات الداعشيه هؤلاء هؤلاء عصابات
قتل يا رج
يقتلون الناس يقتلون العرب السنه قبل
العرب الشيعه قبل الكرد هؤلاء لا ينبغي
توصيفهم تحت اي معيار انساني هؤلاء جماعه
طيب ماشي بس لم تجبني على سؤال انا طيب
ماشي قلت هذا الكلام كيف تفسر لي هذا
التاييد المخفي اي تاييد يا رجل سوريا في
سوريا الناس عم تلعنهم الناس تلعنهم على
انهم جنبا الى جنب النظام قبروا الثوره
قضوا على احلام السوريين في الت
جعب المن ليس بحاجه الى هذه الخلافه
المزعومه وهذه الجرائم التي ترتكب باسم
الاسلام مع الاسف وهؤلاء يسيئون الاسلام
قبل الغير يعني بصراحه السوريون وشعوب
المنطقه تواقون الى بناء دول ديمق الى
الاندراج في العصر في التاريخ تتحدث لي عن
دوله اي دوله يا رجل اين برنامجها
الاقتصادي اين فلسفه الحكم فيها هذه اهانه
لمفهوم السياسه ومفهوم الدوله قال دوله
قال السوريون شعوب المنطقه انتفضوا لبناء
دوله ديمقراطيه للخلاص من الاستبداد
للتعايش يعني لي ليس كل شعوب المنطقه عربا
وسنه هناك نحن مجتمعات تعدديه الدوله
المركزيه الاحاديه الدين او الاحاديه
القوميه سقطت يعني والدليل شوف الحصاد
يعني شوف حصاد هذه الدول الفاشله والمازون
الدوله ام باسم القوميه او باسم الدين
انظر يعني في سوريا الان في العراق قبل
ايام في ليبيا انظر الان عصابات
تتقاتل داعشيه وغير داعشيه بسب القوميه
ليس لا بسبب الاحاديه الاحاديه القومجية
العصابه الداعشيه وقبلها جبهه النصره وهي
شقيقتها هي فرع للقاعده وهذه ايضا خرجت من
رحم القاعده يعني داعش هي الطور الاعلى
النكوص طبعا يعني هذه الحركات
الارهابيه الطور التطوري النكوص للقاعده
لتنظيم القاعده هو التنظيم الام للجماعات
الارهابيه هذه هو يعني هو كما يقال في
مرحلتها الاحتظار يعني حت تسمي طبعا طبعا
يعني هذا القتل العاري وهذا ذبح الناس و
بس بدي احتار بس دقيقه احتار طيب كيف
تسميه حاله داعش او حاله الدوله الاسلاميه
وغيرها احتضار بالله عل خلكم لك اخي والله
انا بدي اسميها مثل ما ههم مسميها يا اخي
يعني بدي اسالك واحد مسمي ابنه جميل وهو
الولد طالع بشع بسميه زعطه يعني بسميه
جميل مثل ما هو فهي مسمي الدوله الاسلاميه
ماشي اسم الدوله الاسلاميه هم مسمينها
ماشي السؤال المطروح ايه انت تقول في حاله
احتضار هي في واقع الامر لو نظرنا الى
الواقع الان نعم
اه انظر اين اصبحت هي اكبر من سوريا تسيطر
على منطقه اكبر من سوريا بمره ضعف مساحه
سوريا 300 وكم كيل متر مربع كيف احتضاري
ثلث العراق صار بايديها قسم كبير من سوريا
بايديها اليوم سيطرت على كل من يعني سيطرت
في سوريا على النفط اليوم سيطرت على ثاني
اكبر حقل للغاز في سوريا نعم تت يعني
اصبحت في كل مكان كيف احتضاري نعم نعم لكن
لا مستقبل لها قد قد تطول هذه الحرب قد
تطول هذه الحرب الدوليه حرب العالم كله
يعني الحرب الان ضد هذا الارهاب الداعشي
ومن فيقه كيف انت تقول احتضاري ووزير
الدفاع الامريكي يقول نحن بحاجه ل 30 سنه
لمواجهتها اذا مش احتضار هي باقيه وتتمدد
كما تقول يا رجل يا رجل هذا فكر لا يمت
للعصر ضد منطق التاريخ ضد منطق الانسانيه
جميل
ر الىو
المشف يتفاخرون ببيع النساء يا رجل هؤلاء
هؤلاء وصمه عار على الجبين الانسانيه
هؤلاء سرطان سيجت من كوباني كوباني ستكون
مقبره هذه الفاشيه كما كانت ستالينغراد في
القرن الماضي هؤلاء الكرد وكردستان
سيكونون مقبره هذه العصابه او التي تسمي
نفسها الخلافه لانهم يعادون الكرد قبل
الغير يعني هذه ايضا تضع علامات استفهام
على من يقف خلفهم الدول المقتسمين
تستخدم هذه الجماعه الارهابيه الظلاميه
العصر حجريه حتى ارب بالقرون الوسطى
القرون الوسطى لم تكن بهذا الانحطاط وبهذه
الحقاره والتخلف وقتل الناس هكذا على
الهويه قتل العرب السنه قبل الاخر جميل
جدا طيب الرجل قال سؤال مهم جدا وانت باحث
في شؤون الخلافه وعندك كتب
بالموضوع نحن ماذا يمكن ان نت اقع من هذه
الجماعات الان بس دقيقه وبهدوء جاوبني اه
ماشي طيب يعني البعض يتساءل اليس من العيب
ان يكون هناك اناس في القرن الحادي
والعشرين يتخذون من طالبان قدوه لهم او من
افغانستان قدوه لهم بس خليك
دقيقه ماذا ان ماذا انجزوا في افغانستان
كي نسير وراءهم ماذا ينجزون في سوريا الان
ماذا انجزوا في العراق جاوبني الان ماذا
يعني انت تقول بس دقيقه انتم تقولون نحن
هزمنا الامريكان في افغانستان ناهم
مليارات الدولارات طيب ماشي لكن وماذا
عمروا ماذا ما هي النتيجه الان في البلدان
التي توجد فيها مثل هذه الجماعات كن
الصومال ولا افغانستان في كل بلد يوجدوا
فيه بيذبحوا بعضهم كيف ترد هناك فرق بين
الجماعات وبين دوله الخلافه الجماعات قامت
لتدعو الى حكم اسلام فابدت في افغانستان
لا يتوقف القصف ليلا نهارا ثم هل تركوا
ليحكموا بسلام رايتم منهم تقصيرا لا لم
يتركوا ليحكموا بسلام حتى الجماعات
المعتدله جدا من المسلميين انقلبوا عليها
انقلبوا عليها لان مصالحهم في الكراسي
والبرلمانات المزعومه
طيب اعرج على نقطه مهمه جداي على سؤ سؤالك
اولا واعرج عن نقطه اخي الكريم نظام
الاسلام نظام الاسلام دين ودوله اما ان
تترك هذه
الدوله تحت القصف ليل النهار وتقول له
ماذا انجزت يا اخي دعني بسلام وانا اريك
هذا انجز لكن الحرب المتواصله التي لم
تهدا على الاسلام منذ كان منذ كان الان هل
تتصور الغرب الصليبي واليهودي واذنابه من
هؤلاء الشراذم التي تعتاش على على قمامه
الصليبيين بس كمل بدون بدون ما
تمت اس شوي قرون ووسطى قرون الوسطى كانت
امجادنا في السماء قرون الوسطى ان تجد
امثالك المهم
ال هؤلاء اسمعني يا اخي شتنا تفضل تفضل
ايه عندما تترك الدوله لتحكم بامان وسلام
عندها تستطيع ان تنجز اما ان تقول لي وانت
تخصني بالطائرات ماذا انجزت الانسان اليوم
لكن السؤال لماذا كل هذا الهجوم عليها انت
اسال نفسك دكتور ونسال كل انسان باحث واعي
لماذا هذا الهجوم لماذا لم يقتلوا نظام
الاسد نظام الاسد الم الم يلعلع بخم نصف
مليون شهيد في سوريا ضمن اكذوبه الثوره
السوريه اكذوبه الثوره السوريه واين
الدوله السوريه اين الدوله التي المرف دون
تسميات ماذا تنجز شهادات الدكتوراه وانت
دكتور كيف تعط في الجامعات يا دكتور ه هل
يعنينا فقط ان بس مش هذا موضوعي مش هذا
موضوعي خليك ما تروح بس دقيقه بس مش هذا
مش هذا موضوعي مش هذا موضوعي بس ماذا يعني
ماذا يعني انت الان تطبل وتزمر لها ما هو
مشروعها في المنطقه مشروعها اقامه اسلام
اقامه دوله اسلام في كل بلاد المسلمين كيف
سيتعامل مع العالم مع العالم العالم في
ساطان في سطاط كفر وفي سطاط ايمان الكافر
عدو المسلم والقتال عادي العالم عادي
العالم كله اي عالم اذا كان العالم
كافر اسكت رجاء العالم مسلم وكافر اخي انت
بحالك وانا بحالي بحكم ببلاد المسلمين اما
انت تهاجمني فليس لك عندي الا الحرب انت
واذناب
اع رجاء نعود الى من ذبحه من السنه
والكلام الفارغ هؤلاء رجاء اسكت البونمر
ماذا كان شانه بس دقيقه بس دقي بس دقيقه
بس دقيقه يا اخي بس دقيقه
دين راس الحربه في يد الامريكان والمجوس
اي مدنيين
شوج المجوس الايرانيين الفرس الفرس مجوس
وانتم بدو الفرس بس دقيقه بس دقيقه
دقيقه كيف ازروا
اليهود لا لا هذا توصيف المؤرخين
الاكرا
دقه دقيقه بس لا بدي اسالك تقول ما هو
مشروعهم وكذا طيب انا بدي اسالك وصلني هذا
السؤال كثيرا طيب عندما انتصرت الثوره
الايرانيه او ما يسمى بالثوره الايرانيه
الاسلاميه نعم نعم العالم كله قاطعها
وعاداه واعتبر انه هذه ثوره لا علاقه لها
لا بالحضاره ولا بال بالمدن ولا باي شيء
ولا بكذا والبعض يتساءل الان ما الفرق بين
داعش وحال لماذا العالم يتحالف مع حالش
ويتعامل مع حالش اللي هو حزب الله والشيعه
والى ما هنالك وايران
اسل خليني اساله لماذا يعني البعض يقوللك
ما الفرق بين ابو بكر البغدادي والخميني
بسالك هلك انت لو لم يكن لديك مشكله مع مع
الدوله الاسلاميه هل كنت تعاديها انت
الاني انت كحزب انت كحزب انت كحزب
ديمقراطي كردستاني صح ولا لا انت لديك
علاقات وثيقه جدا مع ايران انت لديك علاقه
مع حزب الله انت لديك بالبط وهي والجانب
الاخر حالش لا يختلف عن داعش كما يقول
دعني اجيبك نحن في مناطقنا المناطق في روج
المناطق الكرديه في سوريا الان هناك اداره
ذاتيه ديمقراطيه هناك ثلاثه كانتونات نحن
لسنا لا مع هذا المحور السني ولا المحور
الشيعي هناك حرب مذهبيه الان في سوريا في
العراق في في لبنان الفر بين هذا وهذا نحن
من نحن من اليوم الاول للثوره في سوريا
اعتمدنا سياسه الخط الثالث كان لدينا
قراءه استراتيجيه ان مالات ان مالات الوضع
السوري ان ان ان ان عسكره الثوره عسكره لا
ليست تر ولكن لست مستعدا ان ادخل في حرب
تصفيه حسابات قبل 1500 سنه حرب مذهبيه انا
لست انا انا معني بدوله مدنيه دوله
علمانيه دوله ديمقراطيه مي معني بالتعايش
انا انا انا ضد ضد تسييس الدين ضد اسلمه
الدوله والمجتمع نحن ضد كل هذا
نحنا
مقاطعه نحن اعتمدنا سياسه الخط الثالث
لاننا كنا نعرف ان عسكره الثوره وتطييفها
ومذهبها سيخدم النظام وهذا ما حدث بالفعل
انظر الان انظر من الذي خدم النظام اكثر
من الغير داعش والنصره وهذه العصابات
الارهابيه اين هم من اسرائيل اين هذه
العصابه خليك خليك شويه خليك شوي كيف ترد
على كيف ترد انت تقدم انه هذه الجماعات او
هذه الخلافه هي التي وهي وهي وهي كيف ترد
على المسجد الاقصى في
كوب
عند الكافر الاقرب فالكافر الاقرب الكافر
الاقرب فالكافر الاقبر في ك والله لتذبح
وتسب بنسك والله
لاس
سيدفع الثمن والله نساء الكفار تسب
الاكراد على عيني وراسي الاكراد المسلمين
الكرد وليس الاكراد الاكراد الكرد اللي هم
مسلمون منهم 5 500 مجاهد في كوباني الان
في 500 ارهابي قذر كردي قال مجاهد قال 500
مجاهد يقاتلون الان في عين الاسلام والكرد
عين كردستان مجاهد كردي مع في دوله
الخلافه
نل شذا عق من كل الدنيا خليني اسك
الان الكريم دكتور ارجوك اسمحلي نصف ثان
نصف دقيقه نصف دقيقه رجاء نصف دقيقه
مرتزقه مو من جيب الخلفك من الفتوحات
والبترول الذي يسيطرون عليه ال في بلادهم
نعم رجاء رجاء سن سن مادام سادك الامريكان
يقولون
عليك
شهرين شهرين تفتح كوبان كوبان دعست على
رؤوسكم بس بس دقيقه بس
دقيقه الحو الحوار هذه توثيق وانا مسؤول
عنه قانونا هذا توثيق لجرائم
الحزبين بس خليني
اسالك حده ثان
حده لا لا ما را اسمحلك ما رح اسمحلك انا
بدي اسال بدي اسال بدي اسال الان الان يا
اخي انت بهالطريقه هذه والله في افكار
كثير عم بتضيع يا اخي اسمعني اسمعني
اسمعني اسمعني السؤال المطروح الان السؤال
مطروح يقول لك الرجل هو يتحدث عن انه في
حاله احتضار بدك تجاوبني شوي شوي بحاله
احتضار اه يقول لك بحاله احتضار لانه
الشعوب لم تثر الشعوب لاستبدال الفالج
مثلا في سوريا من هو الفالج هو دكتاتوريه
بشار الاسد الفالج ل تستبدلها بسرطان
المتطرفين جاوبي فهمان عليك الثوره
السوريه وغير الثوره السوريه عباره عن
مشاريع استثماريه استعماريه تم طبخها في
الخفاء ودفع اليها ما يسمى الشعب السوري
لاباده المسلمين نعم ما يوجد شعب سوري ولا
يوجد شعب كردي ولا يوجد مسلم وكافر هكذا
جاءت هذه في دين الله تعالى هذه في دين
الله تعالى
ولي روح على توراب انتهينا في بلاد
المسلمين و نخرجك منها رغم انفك تفضل اكمل
اكمل اكم اكم خليه اكمل يا شرزاد خليه
تفضل اك هذا من من ادب الحوار المقاطع
الدائ تضع تفضل هؤلاء هؤلاء الذين
استثمروا ما يسمى بالثوره السوريه ماذا
فعلوا لها حتى الدول التي تحب السوريين لم
تستطع الدول نوعان في هذا الموقف بس خليني
اكمل لك بس خليني كمل هل تستطيع ان تنكر
بانه الاكثر الفرحين الان بهذه الجماعات
وبهذه دوله الخلافه هو النظام السوري الذي
طيب منذ البدايه النظام السوري يقول نحن
لا ن نواجه ثوره شعبيه بل نواجه حركات
خليني اكمل حركات ارهابيه الان كل العالم
يتفق مع هذا النظام ويحارب هذه الجماعات
الارهابيه في سوريا يعني يعني انتم اثبتم
نظريه النظام وتهمه الارهاب ثبتوها على
الارض والعالم الان يحاربهم كارها بيين
اخي الكريم العالم لو كان يريد ان يزيل
النظام لازاله منذ زمن لازال
لهمه اما ان يتحالف العالم مع النظام
فالعالم او او بسبب ذلك ليس بسبب ذلك
العالم مع النظام اساسا لانه لا يجوز في
في في في اتفاق دولي ضمن عام لا يجوز ان
يقوم حكم اسلام في بلاد المسلمين هذا متفق
عليه بين كل دول الكفر ودول الاذناب وكل
الفئات لا يجوز ان يسمح بقيام حكم اسلامي
في بلاد المسلمين لانه ستعود الفتوحات
وانت تعلم ماذا يعني اذا عادت الفتوحات
على الجمال ولا على الاسلحه على الاسلحه
التي يملكونها الان ويطورون ما شاء الله
الصناعيه التي التي تتباهو بانها تصطد
وتزور الفيديوهات و في افغانستان عندنا
كفاءات علميه بفضل الله تعوم ا دقي واليوم
واليوم
اعلنت دقيقه واليوم اعلنت اعلن تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه عن وظائف لمهندسين بترول
بمئات الالاف بس خليني اسال انا بدي اسالك
بدي اسالك شرزات بدي اسالك طيب انت نعود
الى الى مستقبل هذه الجماعات الان طيب
عندما ترى ترى الشعوب العربيه وكل الشعوب
ترى ان العالم يتحالف ضد تنظيم اه تنظيم
لم يفعل الكثير الكثير مقارنه يا اخي
خليني اكمل لك وق لي مقارنه بما فعله
النظام السوري النظام السوري شرد 13 مليون
سوري قتل مليون سوري دمر ثلاثه مليون بيت
دمر المنطقه كلياتها ه جنب داعش طيب دقيقه
هل يعقل انه هالعالم عندما ينظر الى ما
يحدث الان ويرى ان العالم يتحرك بطائراته
بكل شيء ضد تنظيم ويترك القاتل الحقيقي
الا تتوقع ان يهجم الكثيرون لمسانده هذا
التنظيم طيب هل بدي اسالك منذ ان بدا
القصف على هذا التنظيم زاد عدد المنتمين
اليه بعشرات الالاف كيف ترد جاوبني انت
السوري دكتور هل هل تتوقع للحظه ان
السوريون يتعاطفون مع هكذا تنظيم انا يت
بس انا عم ام يعني شو تسالني
داعش اقترفت كما
النظام طيب من المسؤول من المسؤول عن ظهور
هذه الجماعات اليست سياس اليست السياسات
المحليه والدوليه الحقيره كما يسمونها طيب
عندما تترك دقيقه دقيقه بس
دقيقه خلكم خليني اكمل لك انا سالت
علمانيين بعثيين في الموصل بعثيين هل انتم
مع مع تنظيم الدوله قالوا نحن كلنا مع
تنظيم الدوله ليس ليس ح نعم نعم بل لنا
نحن ين س نعم مقتولون من قبل الشيعه في
العراق وفي كل شي دقيقه دقيقه عندما عندما
تجد الشعوب وخاصه المسلمين السنه انهم
بشار الاسد هجرت لاث ارباع السنه في سوريا
بشار الاسد وفي العراق وفي العراق شيعه
ايران هجروا السنه في العراق وفي لبنان
انظر ماذا فعلوا في طرابلس بالامس من حق
حزب الله في لبنان ان يملك الارض وما
عليها لكن حرام على جماعه طرابلس ان يكون
عندهم ثلاث مواريد وق بنادق عندما يكون
لديك هذا عندما يكون لديك هذا الوضع نعم
الا تتوقع ان يزداد عدد هذه الحركات هو
السؤال ولهذا اقول لك يعني انت اشرت الى
الموصل داعش هي ليست فقط سليله القاعده
واسلامو متطرفين داعش هي تزاوج بعثي قاعدي
بقايا البعث الصدامي الان كتفا الى كتف
داعش في العراق وسوريا حتى هذه حقيقه يعني
هو التحالف بعثي قاعدي قذر ضد الكرد
بالدرجه الاولى وضد كافه شعوب المنطقه
لهذا اقول لك هذه العصابه الارهابيه داعش
واخواتها تنتعش في اجواء الاحتقان طيب
وماذا اذا وماذا اذا طالبان وماذا اذا
طالبان بعد فتره اصبحت حاكمه ل كابول شو
بتقول لي بعدها بجيبك بعد شهر شهرين شو
بتسوي يا دكتور بتحني شي يا دكتور بتحني
يا دكتور وهل تريد ان تحول سوريا الى
افغانستان اخرى يا اخي مش عم اقول لك بدي
احولها انا عم بسالك شو مفكرني داعش الان
يعني مش عم بسالك ي داعش انت مش دا جابني
جاوبني جاوبني انا عم بسالك ايه برجع
بسالك انه نعم نعم اناعم طيب بدي اسالك
بدي اسالك برجع بسال سؤال هل استطاعت
امريكا ان تقضي على جماعه الزرقاوي او على
القاعده في العراق خرجت امريكا كان عندها
140 الف جندي وكان عندها طائرات مع ذلك لم
تستطع القضا بس خليني اكمل لك لم تستطع
القضاء عليهم ماشي و و وذهبت الان البعض
يقول انه ها هي امريكا بعد 13 عاما تتفاوض
مع طالبان وبالمناسبه مين اللي ما بده
يفاوض طالبان الامريكان من شان الله تعوا
فوضوه وما بدهم يفوضوا طيب بلكي بعد خمس
سنوات امريكا تطالب بالتفاوض مع تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه شو بتسوي انت دكتور هذا
عم بسالك بعد خمس سنوات هذا اذا بقيت الى
خمس سنوات هذا هو نحن اذا هذه العصابه
الارهابيه هي هي تاتي الى حتفها بقدمها
يعني عندما تختار الكرد وكردستان ليس فقط
في سوريا مناطقنا ككرت في سوريا حتى في
كردستان العراق هي الان تفتح جبه على
امتداد 1500 كر ضدنا من عفرين وكومباني
الى خانقين وكركوك هذه يعني ستكون مقبرته
هذه ليست شعارات هذه ليست شعارات انظر
الان كوباني كوان الان تحولت بس انا بدي
اسالك اعادت الاار ادت الاعتبار لقيم
الكونيه
اذا الناتو حلف الناتو بجلاله قدره لم
يستطع القضاء لا على طالبان ولا على
الزرقاوي لا في العراق ولا افغانستان مع
انه كان عنده كان
عنده نحن سنقضي عليهم في مناطقنا اقول
انني
سذب من يعتدي علينا سندوس عليه كما يحدث
الثل ما سالته طيب البعض يقول ما بعرف هذ
سؤال يوجه لكم
يقال لا
امريكا ولا عرب ولا ايران ولا روسيا ولا
حزب الله يستطيع ان يقضي على هذه
التنظيمات الجهاديه فقط يستطيع ان يقضي
عليها كما قال دمسي قبل فتره المسلمون
السنه لكن طالما ان المسلمين السنه يعانون
القهر والاضطهاد والتمزيق والاقصاء
والتهميش في سوريا في العراق في لبنان في
كل المنطقه فهذه الجماعات ست ترتفع وتزدهر
الى الى الى الى وضع خرافي كيف ترد اخي
اضطهاد باختصار اضطهاد الكفار للمسلمين
ليس فقط اضطهاد الكفار للمسلمين هو الذي
افاق المسلمين من غفلتهم اننا لن نكون امه
محترمه الا اذا عدنا الى خلافتنا الى
ديننا واحكام شرعنا التي لا تعجب الكفار
انهم ي يعني
يسمون ولا ال هناك مسلم رجا اسكت بس دقيقه
رج اسك اسكت من ح اسكت احترمك ما احترم
خليه كمل يا زلمه خليه يكمل يا الله تفضل
ايه هذا الاضطهاد قاد الى هذه النتيجه
ولكن الان نحن امام حكم شرعي دوله الخلافه
دوله الاسلام تمتد على كل اراض بايع فيها
المسلمين هذه الخلافه والاكراد قسم كبير
منهم لا يكذبن عليك هذا قسم كبير منهم
بايع الخلافه يا رجل والله انا اتصل
باربيل وبده ك يانون ويبكون من اضطهادي
الكفار الح في الحزبين وهذه وثائق كرديه
هذه كرديه انا اضعها امانه رئس مل الاداره
الز
اكملي كملي كملي كملي كملي بسالك انا يعني
قطعت
طناس ه انا اطيتز عطيتك الوقت كاملا وقلت
كل
فكرتك اكمل اكمل اكمل ا اكمل انه انه
الشعار الموجود الان باقي يا زلمه الشعار
شعار باقيه باقيه وتتمدد هل هو شعار خرافي
لا ليس هذا هذا شعار الاسلام دوله الاسلام
تتمدد على كل البلاد التي خليني بالمنطقه
اللي فيها هلا في التي فيها والتي في غير
فيها مشروع الدوله الاسلاميه جامع لكل
النا لكل الذين يديننا الان بق
و تتمدد بتمدد سريع جدا انت تر ش انت تراى
هذا التوسع لا تراه في وسائل الاعلام ايو
اه كيف وصلت الى هيت والى جنوب الى
الانبار والى والى والى كل هذا التوسع
اليس هذا تمددا طيب كيف كيف كيف تبرر او
كيف تفسر لنا انه مجموعه صغيره جدا من
المقاتلين تدخل الى منطقه وتطرد عشرات
الالاف من الجنود ك هذا نصر الله تعالى
للمسلمين بس نصر الله هذا نصر الله تعالى
للمسلمين وتاييد الذي يسمونه حاضن الشعبي
الشعوب الان التي تحت حكم غير الخلافه تئ
اليها وتحن اليها
هناك توق لدى الشعوب العربيه دون [__] كلها
الى حكم الشريعه كلها قطع رؤوس الكفار
والسفله والمجرمين اشكرك جزيل الشكر
مشاهدينا الكرام لم يبقى لنا الا نشكر
يفينا السيد حسين محمد حسين
والسيد نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى
ذلك الحين وفيصل قاسم يحييكم من الدوحه
الى اللقاء يعطيكم العافيه يعطيكم العافيه
[موسيقى]
شكرا
ن